[Music]
hello
party people welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for the simpsons hopefully
you've already watched that video right
now because we're gonna talk about it
we're gonna talk about
the simpsons simpsons lore simpsons
history simpson stuff
uh and then we're gonna show you some
deleted scenes we're going to respond to
questions and comments from viewers like
yourselves i'm going to tease you with
next week's honest trailer you know the
drill i'm here with lon i'm here with
danielle how you guys doing today
pretty good we should note this is the
simpsons movie not
the simpsons we didn't watch all 97
seasons of the simpsons
and write a honest trailer about it no i
don't know someday
um some some years don't promise don't
promise that please
because somebody's going to get stuck
with like season 29 and it's just going
to be like a bummer for that yeah
so i guess we should we should start
there which is you know our simpsons
history i think we all
were formed in the crucible of of
seasons one through ten
and have have stuck with it to varying
degrees since
three three through nine really i mean
if we're good season two
there's some there's some season two
gems um it took them like two seasons
it's like seinfeld two like it takes
them like two seasons i'm being generous
yeah to get to like the golden age but
since then
yeah it's it's kind of had this kind of
ship of theseus forget the forgive the
snooty meme of like
they've just replaced the writing staff
and what made the show special
bit by bit over the years to where if
you watch a recent episode even if it's
funny it it bears so little resemblance
to
uh i think what made the show great that
i just can't
uh it's it it just rings hollow to me
but but what do you what about you guys
do you still watch the simpsons
no not really um i i was gonna try to be
like yeah
sometimes but i'm trying to think of the
last one i saw it i think it's when they
did like a thing for apple
but i think they called it like mapple
or something because they couldn't use
the actual
word that's a long time ago i want to
say that's like one of the last episodes
that i saw so it's been a while but i do
i mean obviously i was super into those
first seasons i miss bootleg bart
t-shirts i think yes
bring back reggae bart i had so many
bootleg sims and shirts
it was great uh yeah i mean i i
i still think the simpsons is funny and
like
as good an animated comedy as like most
of what tv
puts out like if you were like lon you
can watch american dad or
a season 32 simpsons i'll be like throw
all the simpsons maybe milhouse is gonna
say something funny
but at a certain point it just it was
this
this incredibly like dense
packed with funny jokes like sort of
take on the sitcom in its early years
and then it shifted at some point to
being like
another tv cartoon like all of the other
tv cartoons for adults
and like that's fine but yeah it lost
like the the thing that set it apart in
the
like yeah well even once it had kind of
begun that
that trend to becoming you know another
kind of funny
enough adult tv show um but it had lost
that kind of cultural cachet and the and
the the fever the simpsons fever had
subsided
uh then they came out with the movie uh
a long time after the afternoon yeah
2007 and i you know
this was the last time i think i got
excited about a simpsons thing and then
i found it a perfectly enjoyable movie
that still didn't have like the magic
of the of some of the early episodes
that uh
that i know and love and will take to my
grave but i think this was a good movie
it was a funny movie that it i don't
know i i've complicated feelings about
this i just
it just didn't grab me the same way that
that i would think one of my favorite
shows of all time would
yeah i think going into the movie you
definitely at that point had the
expectation of like the gang's getting
back together and like
you kind of felt like that's and it's
look it's a good movie uh
same as what lon said if someone gave me
the opportunity to
like i would watch that i'd watch that
again it's a good movie um but yeah
whatever
the whatever the it factor is whatever
the sizzle is in the steak
i was getting no steak sizzle yeah i
think they
they they decided to do a thing that's
that's odd that's unexpected which is it
doesn't so much feel like
let's take the simpsons and blow it up
into like a new thing and make it like
this big screen experience
it was more like let's take a simpsons
episode and just like
stretch it to movie length and we'll
put in some cg and some flourishes to
make it feel like
bigger than just a long episode but that
it's really just a long episode and like
that i think that's especially
noticeable because the movie plot
doesn't really kick in for 45 minutes
because that's what a simpsons episode
does the beginning is like off
in a different pocket of the world and
then you bring it back to what the
main plot is going to be so like all the
spider pig
polluting the lake silo stuff is just
prelude to the real story and i think
that makes it more rewatchable now
like if it was the one-off simpsons
movie we'd probably be like all right
i've seen that
but you could just revisit it because
it's just like a long simpsons episode
now
but it also makes it feel not special
really it's just like
that thing that they did in 2007 that's
kind of fun yeah the simpsons go to
blank
is like an episode format that we've
seen hundreds of times throughout the
show's run
and weirdly alaska is not even a
particularly exciting one and then they
do nothing with
it like they go to alaska he meets one
inuit woman
there's a couple snow jokes yeah and
like then they're done and it's like
well why even
like it just seems like so much to get
them there and then they're like
alaska look at that yeah
let's go back all right gotta head back
oh well uh well let's watch the honest
trailer because i know i have more
thoughts but let's let's make them
relevant to what we're watching uh let's
queue up the honest trailer for the
simpsons movie hit it
[Music]
after 20 seasons of tv and eight
actually good seasons of tv
the worldwide phenomenon that launched a
thousand memes
finally comes to the big screen at least
a decade after anyone over the age of 12
stopped giving a crap
it's like if they put out a family guy
movie now
go the simpsons movie
remember this is is family guy still on
uh maybe yes it is it's a tv show oh
yeah it's definitely still on tv
so there's american dead they're both
making new episodes they are yeah
unbelievable cleveland though show
though all right keep that one going
and they wrote them back in fashion
yeah and i think that like to
there's always like three or four other
adult animated shows
roaming around like at any one time and
like they seem good
i just can't get myself to watch like i
don't know f
is for fans i really like like i really
like bob's burgers
and they are also getting a movie and
i'm looking forward to
watching it i've liked the episodes i've
seen in that um
yeah i think that one is really good and
and has its own
it doesn't feel like it's just another
like simpsons clone or it's trying to do
kind of the same
beats it really feels
yes you're right great north or yeah
right north or something like that yes
you're right
i've seen it on hulu there's like a
little thing i don't know i
there there haven't been many
innovations is what i'm saying uh since
the simpsons uh
in like i don't know i i gotta i gotta i
gotta disagree with you once again
there's a lot there's like
hbo max too has close enough from the
regular show guy which i've been
enjoying and
infinity train which is amazing and is
coming back for season four like
i think you maybe should explore your
adult animated options a little more
all right well okay something to get
into fair enough uh all right keep going
the simpsons they're back in movie form
for a film that you'd swear was just a
long episode of the show
if it weren't for some weird digital
animation shots and a big dose of
edginess that no one asked for
featuring lynches boobs
and bart stick good luck sneaking all
that under disney plus
i'm the mascot of an evil corporation
that's awkward
like i don't know i i i do you think
that like the writers just were they had
all these dick jokes like in reserve
that they just couldn't get
past fox or something like that because
i feel like the edginess adds nothing to
the simpsons
uh it actually makes it like somewhat
worse for me oh it's um
it's oh because now it's awkward because
you're like well this isn't how this
show should be it just feels
off yeah yeah so it is worse absolutely
no it's just like seeing um i don't know
mickey mouse say the f word like
well i think it's the same thing i was
saying before which is
it it feels like they didn't really make
a movie they just made a long show and
then they were like but we have to make
it feel like a movie somehow
and so you know i was like well put put
dick and boob jokes in it then it'll
feel like a movie and yeah
maybe it was like the south park movie
they were like that's what they did
was you got a heightened when you go to
a theater yeah
yeah just most movies don't have just
random ds in it i guess
it was a choice random little boy ds uh
yeah and the south park movie i think is
the good
example of like all right what can we do
that's different well
it more naturally fits the show that
they could curse finally
and and they made it a musical like they
made a movie musical
the thing with south park is right
tonally it was already like as edgy as
you could be on comedy central so it
makes sense to make the movie like well
it's gotta be more edgy but the simpsons
isn't
pushing the at least not since like 1990
when you know
people were upset with bart for being an
underachiever but that's not the
spirit of that show is like envelope
pushing
what can we get away like i'm sure the
family guy movie will have like
full frontal live-action nudity or
whatever finally
yeah or just conway twitty for 80
minutes
performing a concert all right keep
going the simpsons
a perfect representation of how harvard
nerds envision a middle class family
lisa is an inconvenient truther who can
resist an environmentalist or a guy with
an accent
much less both is your name as pretty as
your face
[Music]
marge is so fed up with being right she
tapes a divorce message over her wedding
video
i'm leaving with the kids to help
springfield
and we're never coming back it's funny
because it's true
born is acting out that was some first
of all some amazing voice acting i think
we all yes
we all pointed out what a what a scene
um that
you don't get that on the show too often
it's like the real kick to the gut
um uh used to when and when it was still
more of like a show and less of like a
goofy zany cartoon they would there
would be moments of pathos like this but
fewer today than there used to be yeah
she definitely like
she did some different stuff with her
voice and for me when i was watching
this because i
saw it in the theater like that was the
moment i was like oh okay yeah now i see
like it's a
it's a movie like that was for me more
than seeing d
uh without note without expecting it was
the moment when it was like oh
shoot march is getting real um so i
guess maybe
more moments like that would have been
cool yeah and then going back to
uh the moment before that of like lisa
and colin like
i don't know like i feel like she gets a
crush on that kind of boy a million
times
uh before and like they didn't even cast
a celebrity like there's nothing
interesting about
about that kid or that relationship they
didn't really give
lisa anything not that they do too often
yeah it did feel like it was just
something for lisa to do while everyone
else got to be in the movie
yeah yeah it just i think the the note
uh
which i believe was your spencer like
the lisa always dates the same like
environmentalist with an accent
like it's more interesting when they
pair lisa up with like nelson like in
that episode where she
it's like an opposites kind of thing
they they go to this
well a lot yeah like oh it's the movie
like lisa and milhouse will finally get
together like right see what happens
um yeah
all right keep watching barn is acting
out because he's missing a strong
authority figure
which might be why he turned to
scientology for answers hey what's
happening man this is bart simpson
just kidding don't hang up this is nancy
cartwright i'm now auditing on new
ot7 and by this point in simpson's
history homer has evolved from a flawed
but caring father into an irredeemable
jerk ass crossed with wiley coyote
okay enough looney tunes stuff get back
to the child abuse i'll teach you to
laugh
at something that's funny laughter
i mean the show was a the movie really
centered on like
homer and marge's relationship and like
homer coming to
coming to terms and realizing you know
that he's been an absentee or a bad
bad husband and needed to start living
for other people but like
i don't know i just thought it was kind
of cheap that that happened in like
three minutes all thanks to the boob
lady like
he didn't do anything himself where he
realized that he'd ruined anything he
just
you know he had a dream sequence and
then even after that he wasn't a very
good guy
anyways but we also we've dealt with i
think we
bring up later that that's already like
i know simpsons did it but they did the
the dream sequence fantasy drug trip
where he realizes he's not a good
husband
the uh guatemalan insanity pepper
episode where he
is at the chili cook-off so it i mean
it would be nice if for the movie they
could at least come up with a beat they
hadn't used in a well-known episode
yeah oh well all right keep going
laugh along with all the hilarious side
characters you know and love
until a cheap hank scorpio knockoff
traps them all under a dome
leaving us with plenty of time for the
simpsons to poke fun at alaska
okay while the residents are spring
pause right here so this is
to me i think the biggest missed
opportunity um
in that like this it's called the
simpsons but it's about
springfield at this point certainly by
2007 like
there's so many other characters that
we've spent so much time with and love
for so many different reasons like i
don't think principal skinner like talks
in this entire movie there's so many
people we don't get to hear from
and i'm not saying that you have to make
this like a was that episode like 21
tales of springfield
two short stories about springfield yeah
it doesn't have to be that but like
there's just missed opportunities like
introducing the new epa guy villain
instead of using an old character
instead of using mr burns or something
like that and like the
lisa's boyfriend being uh introducing a
new nothing character
instead of using milhouse or nelson or
something like we didn't
i know that their plan was like okay
we're just making this about like the
simpsons family
but i don't think that's why we like the
show per se
it's it's bigger than that thoughts
yeah i mean i think you're i think
you're right i think it was probably
like i think the dome thing and like
springfield stuck and they have to like
like we go back and it's become this
like mad max post apocalypse with mo
is like the like that's the i'd rather
see that movie like
don't go to alaska it's just springfield
surviving
under this dome cut off from the world i
feel like that's the more fun movie that
i'd rather watch
yeah i want to see like the decline in
how all of the characters that i love
react to it for sure exactly
yeah and just like i want to see
sideshow bob or mr burns or like someone
i know
be the threat or or have to work
together with them or something
listen kelsey works a lot maybe he was
unavailable
you're a very busy man like you know we
don't know what
you know what was going on with frasier
at this time yeah
i'm just saying you know boob lady and
and uh you know
uh epa guy like we're not talking about
them
the only standout character albert
brooks i know excited to bring him back
because it was like he's a legendary
voice guy from the show
yeah but just uh i don't know the the
the standout character and joke from
this movie
was spider pig is very telling to me
it's like
that that was just kind of a throwaway
gag um
and uh yeah anyways yeah well
i think i think what you what you said
right there at the end is is really like
the key like
throw away gags like it's so we're just
like on this
crazy narrative path through all these
different scenarios
and i think what people love about the
show is right like just checking in with
random springfieldians and getting like
one or two like funny bits with them
like
there's no hans mole man there's no
professor frank there's no
you know like all of that part of the
world we don't ever get to see because
we are
spending so much time on the simpsons
yeah they made him
president schwarzenegger instead of
president wolf castle i mean come on
yeah we're doing yeah i don't like that
i don't understand that at all like they
just thought
it was like got to bring in new fans who
don't know rainier wolf castle yeah and
that's not like a deep
such a deep cut that somebody who'd
never seen the simpsons can't be like oh
that's supposed to be arnold
schwarzenegger like
it's fine yeah anyways all right keep
going
while the residents of springfield
descend into a mad max style apocalypse
camera i am now the emperor of
springfield
oh i want to see the emperor moe movie
maybe that's where spider pig went for
the second half
oh no they ate him didn't they
experience the thrill of watching all
the best simpsons writers returning
to reuse plot lines from episodes they
made decades ago
featuring the simpsons kids being raised
by the flanders multi-eyed creatures
born of illegal water pollution
and native american vision quests
prompted by spicy food
boy please hey simpsons movie simpsons
did it
but if the franchise is known for
anything these days it's predicting the
future
as you know we've inherited quite a
budget crunch from president trump
and this film is no exception completely
nailing the plot of stephen king's next
book
tom hanks becoming more credible than
the u.s government the u.s government
has lost its credibility so it's
borrowing
some of mine and the mandalorian
i have spoken so gather around for a
good but not great simpsons experience
which is still light years ahead of most
of the other comedies you could be
watching on disney plus
sorry for the first kid slander first
kid fans
and while it's become our national past
time to complain about the show's
declining quality
we'd all watch a sequel to this in a
heartbeat
see you in 2035 movie
yeah i mean
why don't they have this at this point
have a movie like
done i don't know like it was a huge
success
um i know it was hard to write because
they're doing the show at the same time
um and it's like that's a lot but maybe
maybe get the old writers to be working
on that while the new ones are cranking
out the show like
i don't know we we've got it you know
that they're watching
very closely at disney what viewership
on disney plus is like
on this thing and from like we don't get
numbers
from any of these platforms but the the
vibe
seems to be that the simpsons is doing
really well on disney plus and a lot of
people are watching it so
i have to feel like if that continues
uh they're gonna make more it's not just
gonna be new episodes of the show
they'll keep making
simpsons spin off media just to get
people
to stay on disney plus longer so yeah i
feel like
another film franchise or some kind of
spin-off project or something can't be
too far off
yeah and it seems like a better fit
honestly is to do it like something
streaming that you're gonna watch on tv
for that show
because it is a tv show at heart and you
would be
you'd fall into fewer of the pitfalls of
like oh we need to
put a bunch of weird 3d in here um or
like oh
and i think that we were talking about
the 22 short stories about springfield
that's a perfect template because there
is like
the main simpson show of course it's
always going to be coming back to like
homer and bart and marge
it's that they're the main stars but you
could do other fun stuff with there's so
many characters it's such a big world at
this point
and you know there was just um another
actor
kevin michael richardson i think is his
name is taking over the voice of dr
hibbert
on the simpsons from hank uh harry
shearer is not going to do it anymore
um and i was i was reading that article
yesterday it's like how often does dr
hibbert even get to speak that guy's
gonna get to say four lines this season
but like that's he's a funny character
like you could have him in more
stuff yeah i'd watch a moe's spin off
for sure like that sounds like that
would be really fun
and you would still get kind of your
dose of characters that you like you
know right and there must be so much
like built up reservoir of jokes that
they never got to use for all of these
minor side characters like
you know every simpsons writer has like
a hans mole man bit
they've never gotten like put that all
in something
i would watch the hans mole movie for
sure yeah and they just about
that pain in which he lives every day
what was that right sorry lon they made
that maggie
short too and put it in front of onward
a year ago and then put on disney plus
so that would suggest that they're still
interested in producing new simpsons
spin-off content
and even you know putting it in
different places yeah this is
a viable ip they're not going to just
let it let it die
no you've got chess sets to sell should
it die
another calypso album perhaps i think
if this could i think this could
transition from a tv to a film franchise
uh because i think that we've uh we've
gotten every last drop
out of out of them as a sitcom but
that's just one man's opinion
um but i'd still like to see them i'd
like to be reminded of the simpsons
every
two to five years um but i don't think
it needs to be every night
um anyways let's keep going
starring american king of the family guy
[Music]
small fry gal gore simpson
she's mute she's cute she scoots through
shoots
the prophet abraham plucky charms
spider pig will return in spider-man 3.
jank scorpio and fandom
i've spent my entire life doing nothing
but collecting comic books
and now there's only time to say
life well spent infinite seasons in a
movie
well during the avalanche scene homer is
carrying four logs
and three logs then four logs again i
mean what are we supposed to believe
this is some sort of
magical log or something boy i really
hope somebody got fired for that blunder
so there you go that's the second or
third simpsons reference we buried
into we baked into the honest trailer
itself uh
there's about that many in every episode
so
if you can spot them all so many casts
so many references to rich creamery
butter
what are we doing uh thank you guys so
much for watching
uh uh up until this point um and if
you're here at this point
uh subscribe like hit that bell do all
that stuff
because you don't want to miss one
little thing we say
uh or uh you know you want to win some
money so
um our sister channel uh fandom games
has a phantom five episode coming up uh
with the debut of host bailey myers
who we know and love uh she'll be uh
quizzing everyone on nintendo
the man the brand the myth the legend
all all things related to nintendo
you can win a whole bunch of money
hundreds of real dollars
so go sign up for that because that is
this friday
um and with that we come to the moment
where we find out what jokes were
not even funny enough for what we just
did let's look at
if they didn't even make that they
didn't even make it into
that so let's see what got cut from the
simpsons honest trailer
starring daniel poo pig that'll poo
homophobia
divorce alaskan style blue hair do glare
all's hair in love and chores bard man
beyond
99 problems and a pig is one vada
thundberg
one of the only people in town with
eyebrows baby's day out
of the dome irish springfield
finding domi scene squealer
kevin bacon the simpsons content
homer's odyssey dome improvement
there what okay well it's missing a few
things um there was one joke about it
being
uh you either die
and influence south park or you're on
the air right long enough to want to
become
software some joke like that and then
there's an alternate tag
that i will tell you about in three
seconds
which was um yeah we had to oh yeah
because we repurposed that for the
mandalorian thing nevermind
um that's all we got so uh let's move on
to your
questions what do you guys have to say
um james bunt writes what other tv
cartoon would you like to become a major
motion picture for me the venture bros
that's a great
idea james um i would watch that i would
i would pay for the pleasure
uh yeah that would be good um
i don't know king of the hill i'd watch
a king of that movie uh
i mean i already shouted out some of my
current faves like an infinity train
movie would be really cool but i'm gonna
go ahead also throw out
uh a tie like a show that crossed over
with the simpsons once
the critic which i feel like time is now
bring back the critic what's john lovitz
doing cameo nothing
get it back that'd be fantastic yeah
that was totally going to be mine was
the critic i
i as a young child i had way too much in
common i think with that
oh yeah i totally related to jay and
marty sherman in an unhealthy way
it's a young person but also i feel like
it almost the critic almost like makes
more sense
now than it did then like back then
people were like parodies of like
random movies like who cares whereas
today a show that
like had a way to constantly make fun of
like geek and nerd
movie content would be a huge hit yeah i
think dr
katz would also be a good one oh
brilliant
yes you know my my dream already came
true because i got beavis and butthead
do america
and aqua teen hunger force colon movie
film for theaters
in in my lifetime so i don't need any
more uh
i got everything i wanted yeah i saw
that aqua teen movie
yeah that was one of my most memorable
movie theater experiences because
i saw it on 4 20 and the all the theater
employees thought it'd be funny to dress
up as cops
[Laughter]
which was hilarious in retrospect you
should get some sort of award like adult
swim should mail you something if you
saw both that
and tim and eric's billion dollar movie
in theaters yeah i rented that one in
theaters nice okay
that was a i had to watch that 15
minutes at a time i think that
they are absolute geniuses and yet i
don't think i can take two hours
straight or my or my brain will explode
yeah i understand
um all right worm for worm right uh did
y'all ever go on the simpsons ride at
universal
i think i did i i i know i went i got a
flaming moe
i know i went to like the springfield
and and had a a
donut and a flaming moan that was both
delicious but i i
i have not been to universal since they
opened the like
mock springfield land but i did go on
that ride when it was
new like right after they turned the
back to the future right into it
uh it was fun yeah yeah it's one of
those like shaky box rides i don't know
it's like star tours you're in a you're
in a you're in a thing and it's moving
like this
and then you've got a movie playing and
they make it feel like you're
flying around not my fave uh confirmed
the orlando one is also just that
ah bummer oh it's fun
you know it's not like a roller coaster
but it's it's something
adam halbert writes has there ever been
a movie based on a tv show that's
actually on par with the tv show
hmm uh yes uh the answer is twin peaks
firewalk with me oh which is in its own
way i think maybe the best
among the best twin peaks content ever
ever made
yeah yeah that's a good point i was
going to say friday night lights but
that's the orders reversed
right it was the movie first and then it
was and then like i don't know do you
count
21 jump street like that's no those are
like
remakes so that means like the the movie
continues
or was it inspired by like serenity for
fireflies
because otherwise i would say the the
90s brady bunch movie like i like that
more than
watching the actual brady budge yeah
you could say uh if you if you'll allow
uh borat as part of the leg show
um as an extension of that sure yeah i
think mcgruber would go in there
probably
um if you count the snl movies sure
there's a bunch that are way better than
snl
um yeah or uh or entourage you know the
the entourage movie of course and the
city too
yeah oh actually uh speaking of hbo
movies though the deadwood movie
was excellent so i would count that
let's check that out
uh and then finally jim one writes let's
end on a downer
uh do you think disney will or should
continue making simpsons episodes when
the main voice cast decides to retire
i don't think they should be making
episodes now um i i really don't i just
i
and it's not just i'm not singling out
the the simpsons i think i'm
sort of consistent and saying like let's
just let things end and die so that new
things can rise to take their place like
it's okay to have a lifespan
uh and and to bow out um
but simpsons hasn't quite gotten there
yet
because i guess the voice cast is all
still down to do it um why wouldn't they
be
um but the the only creative
staff person left is is al gene right
from
from the olden days like he's the only
the only guy left and everybody else has
has nothing to do with uh what what
created the show you know and love i
mean a lot of the
the people who are writing it at its
absolute peak have been gone
for decades like you know john
schwarzwelder came back to like help out
with the movie but he hasn't been a
regular writer in forever like all those
guys
uh i don't know i mean to me at this
point it's like it's a cultural
institution if there's a younger
generation
that's into it and wants to keep
watching it like yeah i don't unders
keep on making it it is one of those
things where i feel like you're gonna
have to do
like the mickey mouse bugs bunny like
you can't just recast it
and now they sound different you gotta
like find somebody who can sound like
dan castellaneta doing homer
or it doesn't work you know like you got
to kermit it a little bit i think
yeah if i'm those voice actors i'm never
leaving i'm building a
booth a sound booth above my bed and i'm
taking the millions of dollars that
they're throwing at me
um so you know in the case that they
ever do retire i think they'll go the
same route that you just said you'd just
find
like a good sound alike i don't see any
of these guys like suddenly deciding
okay we're all just gonna go ahead and
leave because that's
so much money they are already though
bazillionaires but
you know i guess they trade at all they
trade it all for a little more
yeah it's creative freedom for some of
these
some of these folks too like you know
harry shearer can do
like brock meyer yeah zaria could do
that harry shear could do like he does
you know shows at the largo in la he
does like music stuff he's got like a
radio show like
he probably wants to do a lot of stuff
that doesn't pay that well and so he can
use this as his way to like fund all
that other stuff like
i think it totally makes sense for all
those folks from that perspective
yeah that's true because you're lee
smith just shows up places that you
never expect her to be so
right yeah like you know like you
haven't seen julie cavner onto you she
was like a great actress isn't hannah
and her sister she was like really you
know acting on screen but like she
doesn't have to work anymore if she
doesn't want to because she's marge
yeah yeah i think we'd all take that
deal uh
who wouldn't
anyway i hope we uh hope we run some
laughs out of this uh
otherwise sad episode um because it's
sad to see things grow old and or
including ourselves and grow out of the
things we loved
as as kids and yet um uh
still a decent enough movie that i was
happy to rewatch it uh and i hope you're
happy enough to come back and re-watch
this show
cause we will be back next week uh when
we will be doing a show
an episode about um let's just say some
other comedy royalty
next week is about comedy royalty uh and
we will see you
then for another episode of australia's
commentaries thanks guys
[Music]
you